we got 1 30 a.m in the UK oh man
oh man
check check
there we go there we go okay so I didn't
as I was saying that retro guy I didn't
change up
the spacing of anything but I have
started to
you move this oh wait hold on right
there
I have started to kind of figure out
what you know I think we can kind of use
this as like a little themed area
so I have this pumpkin
that my kids love to have out there I
guess a jack-o'-lantern technically it's
not a real pumpkin but it's just one you
plug in and it lights up
so I'm like that might be fun to have
this is kind of like a rotating
whenever around holidays have holiday
themed so we can get like the
jack-o-lantern and then we can go like a
Christmas tree
and then we just go back to something
like this later on but so yeah that's
all I've changed
and eventually we're gonna have I feel
like we need something right here
maybe on this side too yeah so like but
the positioning of the room I'm pretty
happy with the position of the room oh
yeah
so much for becoming a channel member
noob 9227
[Music]
Trevor Morris as well oh wait we got
five gifted we got five gifted it's
Elwyn again
Ellen coming through with the five
gifteds
Danny Soderberg just got one of the
gifted memberships guys make sure you
thank elwin if you got one of these
gifted memberships
Olimar 92
. is that a Pikmin fan
maybe maybe Captain Olimar
and Neil a I remember Neil from last
time welcome Neil
oh yeah you like the shirt Logan yeah
this was an old Christmas gift from a
buddy gosh I've had it for a long time
now
but yeah it's pretty it's pretty cool
let's see it goes all the way
hold on
it's got quite a lot of spells on there
actually
we got the Harry's go-to though right
here at the top you know that one's in a
prime spot
thank you so much Elwyn very much
appreciated Elwyn always showing love
and support for the stream all right
let's see who we got in the house
tonight we got Dr sherbet here which we
all know how to say sherbet now after
the last stream Noob who just got one of
those gifted memberships is here as well
royal blue was in the house early I
don't know if royal blue is still here
nose of Sauron is back with us knows I'm
sorry what's up soundtrack is here yet
again
Dylan in the house hey what's up Dylan
Nico is here as well Dylan and Nico
fellow channel members fellow moderators
of the stream as well thank you guys so
much for being here
Let's see we got Logan in the house
elwin of course another dude we got two
Logan's
oh that's funny so we've got Logan who
has kind of a
oh they both have faces in their avatars
too one is kind of like a yellow face
that looks like a statue
it's hard for me to tell it's so tiny
and then the other one is a guy on a
like a pink purplish background so we
got two Logans in the house
Logan's welcome back Artemis is here
fandom draws hey welcome back fandom
draws we got a lot to talk about this
time you guys careless dreamer just
became a channel member as well oh wait
was that five more gifted I think we
just got five more gifted we got a two
months from Machop Machop thank you so
much for the two months
and then we got five gifted from retro
guy gaming we just re re-uh welcome to
Griffin what is the word it's not
re-subbed here on YouTube rejoined is
rejoined retro guy gaming rejoined how
are you and now just gifted five
Elizabeth Jack got one of the gifted
members memberships guys thank you so
much bristolboy88 just got one of them
if you got one of the gifted memberships
make sure you thank the person who
gifted it to you what do you get you may
ask maybe you just stumbled into the
chat Jesse with a super chat as well the
five dollar Super Chat love your content
bro hey Jessie thank you so much for the
support dude thank you so much man I am
having a blast making Hogwarts Legacy
content and
have a video 90 of the way done that's
should be hitting tomorrow so it's kind
of recapping I wanted to wait till this
afternoon and see if they had another
drop today but they didn't so I'm just
gonna go ahead and go with what we got
which then they're probably gonna drop
new stuff tomorrow but yeah thank you
all for the support man this is awesome
great way to start the Stream
uh retro guy gaming though so yeah we
were saying what do you get if you're
somebody who just maybe this is your
first time stumbling in and you just got
gifted one of these like what the heck
is this so on YouTube subscriptions are
free
but memberships actually cost money so
those people gifting you the memberships
they actually paid money to support the
channel but in turn you get a gifted
membership for it and so you unlock
several new emoji that are pretty slick
we've actually unlocked four new slots
and I've got I think I have the ideas
finalized I just need to descend it over
to the designer so you get access to
those you can use in the chat you can
also use on any of my videos as well
then uh I have discounted merch so
there's a YouTube Community page if you
go to my YouTube channel and then hit
Community there's a little area where
you can see all the little benefits that
you get as being a member and it's just
like little things I mean mostly the
memberships are a way for people to
support uh support the Channel show some
love to the channel and then I try to
throw something back in return so the
Emoji are just a little fun thing you
can do and then there's some other
things in there as well like like I know
discounted merch is one and priority
reply on comments a little little things
like that but but cool things I hope you
guys think they're cool anyway but man
yeah so we got five gifted another five
gifted we had someone rejoin as another
member then we had the super chat now we
got a three months from Nico
and Nico choosing to plug our merch with
his uh comment here
so yeah it's uh I think it should post
that in the chat right yeah I'm clicking
on it where it gives me the little uh
update but then we just had oh my gosh
Logan with another five gifteds
dude
why is that one not popping through yet
to everybody oh no there you go there it
goes there it goes
congratulations Lee Logan thank you so
much dude I remember Logan has been here
for several streams in a row soft-spoken
one one just got one of the gifted
memberships as well
this this the uh slow mode is not
helping at all Aaron Brewer oh my gosh
is this the Aaron Brewer that plays for
the Tennessee Titans my favorite NFL
team
that'd be insane
fandom draws yo fandom draws with a
gifted membership as well let's go
see this is the I love I love all the
gifteds because you get to wait and see
and Jesse Jesse just got gifted a
membership as well I think Jesse is one
who just uh
Jesse just gave the five dollars in the
Super Chat and now noob
what is what is going on
is it it's not my birthday or anything
guys it's not I promise oh how are you
welcome is it is it uh Christmas early
early Christmas gifts guys thank you so
much this is awesome
very much appreciate the support how are
you welcome to Emily with one of the
gifted so MIA guys this is how generous
our community is it's crazy they are so
incredibly generous if you are one of
those people maybe you've been lurking
for a while and you just got gifted one
of these memberships you could stay
lurking but just just hop in for just a
moment just to say thank you just make
sure you say thank you and then you
could go back to lurking that's it Zone
M24 gifted a membership as well
I didn't even get I'm not even halfway
through catching up on all of the uh I
wanted to shout out everyone how are you
who is here hanging out tonight
and then all the gifteds just started
rolling through so sorry the gifted they
get bumped up over
just shouting out for being here the
gift of memberships they jump to the top
of my list and then when you get a five
dollar Super Chat that jumps to the top
of the list as well retro guy gaming
with the five dollar Super Chat
same favorite NFL team no way number two
is the bills oh man dude well they they
beat up on the Titans pretty good this
year but Titan's got a lot of injuries
right now hopefully they'll be able to
ride the ship
it's kind of crazy because last year
they were they had some ups and downs
and then end up the number one seed so
who knows it's still so early right now
you just wanna you know
win win some division games stay stay
around or above 500 then get hot towards
the end but yeah bills are looking
really good though
really good that's a big comeback win
for them last week
all right so
let's see if we can I think I got
Artemis I got Phantom draws Jason Hodges
Channel member is here tonight as well
uh we got Nico we got nose of Sauron we
got Bantam draws my high nine Sherbert
pronounced sheer bet you all was wrong
the last time
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
hey we could have a uh pronunciation on
how to pronounce or tonight
you guys don't know what that's about
make sure you check out my latest uh
Hogwarts Legacy video
the aurors aurors or aurors
oh my gosh man like I don't think I've
ever gotten
more comments about a single thing than
me mispronouncing
order
or sounds so auror
it sounds so weird to me that's why I
think I I try to change it to auror
because at least RR is like that's how
it looks a-u-r-o-r but or it's just like
it's like the word order but you're
taking out the D that's what it's like
instead of order it's or or
just sounds so weird to me man now I
think it's probably because it's a you
know she's British
so when she says the word when Stephen
Fry says the word when Jim Dale say the
word it probably sounds like Aura aura
which sounds much more pleasing much
more pleasant than horror the aurors are
on their way Tom
oh my gosh so no man that was it was
honestly hilarious how many comments I'm
actually kind of encouraged by it
because it came at the end of the video
so I'm like hey that means people are
actually watching through to the end of
the video I'll take it I will take it
stream elements is here stream elements
hopefully you can get your Bot working
tonight stream elements come on man
Olimar 92 Neil we got Guillermo we got
Danny we got elwin we got halberry or is
it hallberry
Olimar Let's see we settle more we said
Danny Colonel Channel member here is
hanging out Brittany Smith is hanging
out tonight uh Jesse we already called
out Emily in skylines music welcome back
I feel like I remember seeing skylines
music before star Hopper channel member
is here Trevor Morris how's it going
Trevor
we got Let's see we already talked about
Santiago Gator fan I remember Gator fan
from last week as well
oh well CJ come on dude you gotta have I
mean there you go we'll let that be your
shout out
well let that be your shout out CJ thank
you so much for the Super Chat very very
kind of you to support the channel
careless dreamer Jenny Channel member is
here all right we're getting caught up
now okay so this is where the slow
Mode's starting to help out a bit
wait hold on
u m u t i n c e
umet ins
I feel like that's one of those that's
trying to get me to say something that I
shouldn't hold on
human
No Maybe not maybe not I don't know
welcome good to have you here shadowyn
is back as well qwerty
and a bunch of letters after that QWERTY
thank you so much for being here and
hanging out
uh let's see Star Hopper Jesse Timothy
ninja Machop Channel member Machop
Dr Robo Panda another Channel member
welcome back Robo Panda Levi Channel
member is back as well Dustin is here in
the house
all right see we're getting there Jay
Rossi dude Jay Rossi how have you not
got a gifted J Rossi is here like every
stream and we get so many gifteds and I
I can't believe Jay Rossi hasn't been
one of the gifteds yet
J Rossi is always here what's up Jay
Rossi
oh Phantom draws asking about slow mode
exactly there you go g-rock I mean see
look look how far behind I am already
even with the slow-mo
shadowing got an hour and a half left of
work always glad for some content to
help pass last bit of your shift nice
Batman game what is up pre-ordered
Hogwarts Legacy digital deluxe edition
on PS5 let's go
and I think we are oh wait we got Moon
we got deep Squad hey what's up D Squad
welcome Nick and Angie oh it's your name
in Turkish
nice
I mispronounce a lot of things
apparently so my apologies you have to
try and help me uh help me pronounce
that one
Gabe in the house as well the Mr red
s are going to start saying words
hey that's a good idea Mr red Chris
Berkland Channel member is here Rowena
is here James Lowry Trey wait I just I
think I just missed a bunch J creel Mr
danox Dylan bro yo we got another Dylan
foreign
s BM dead Rock Cascadia Ashley oh yeah
it just skipped it just skipped over all
these I thought I was caught up Maisie
the dog
a veking nine nine Kevin
uh Talon price
is here as well
feathers a channel member feathers
welcome back Nicholas
okay we got my chop we got Moon we got
Zone we got uh Elizabeth I don't think I
saw Elizabeth yet welcome Elizabeth
Channel member extra white is back again
as well
and
Gallifrey okay wait Gallifrey got one of
the gifted memberships
all right all right all right
all right if I missed you my apology oh
sir Archibald
there you go got you two
all right now let's scroll back down
let's scroll back down
let's scroll back down Phantom says I
say it the weird way auror
well that's the I think how you're
saying it there is the correct or or is
the correct
first of all chat that was so hateful to
me it's a made-up word
we could we could pronounce it however
we want
oh man but
it's up to you on saying a sherbet or
yeah Sherbert right that's another one
just as bad as an unforgivable curse oh
Noob come on come on now
expect to go with saying since the state
of play the massive Merlin statue has a
pensive under it uh yeah I think he's
probably right about that Gator yeah I
think he's right that that's offensive
Jesse coming in with a super chat as
well yo Jesse thanks so much for the
Super Chat and showing love to the
channel panda hat in the house as well
okay
all right so let's
all right all right all right all right
I think we are caught up Marvis Jolly we
got Geek Squad
Jay Rossi says I don't think I have the
option uh okay gotcha gotcha
Panda Potter one
is here paying a Potter just like so so
ready to talk Hogwarts Legacy hey I mean
I appreciate the enthusiasm I do I do
but when I when I got people gifting and
shouting out and
sharing the love around channel members
I mean I gotta shout them out that would
be rude not to it'd be rude not to
yeah it's made up word
and you know what guys it won't happen
again it'll be just Aura from here on
out it'll sound like I'm chewing a hot
dog or or
you know like it's like
or the or the ores man the ores are on
the way
said or like on the first recording I
said ores and like wait what that just
doesn't sound right
all all Roars the aurors the aurores now
everybody's like ours bro oh my gosh
you know what just relax people relax
just relax it'll be okay
no man it's all in good fun though it's
all in good fun
Universal canceled their Fantastic
Beasts expansion
wait what did they even
I didn't even know they were planning of
I don't think I knew they were planning
a fantastic Beast expansion
that's kind of crazy though I wonder if
they got word that the movies are not
[Music]
oh I wonder if they're gonna be done
with the movies
Rossi I mean that's what I'm saying dude
Aura ex exactly exactly that's what I'm
saying
oh man
all right enough about that we got
people getting a little antsy in the
chat they get a little
a little antsy like what is this dude he
said he was gonna have new no I mean
we're talking about the latest news guys
like it's not like it's not like break
it's not like there's something emerging
like
it's not like Chandler just dm'd me
something we're just we're just
recapping the news
from the past couple days
the rack and touring is occurring yeah
we're all caught up now in that seat I
mean that's when we got the slow mode on
look how long it took me to catch up
even with slow mode
Dylan this community is so awesome what
is happening Dylan this is like every
week dude
this is like every week I can't even get
I can't even get started
and it's it's
the Hogwart I mean it
it's definitely my community here but
it's larger like the Harry Potter and
Hogwarts Legacy Community too if you go
to my buddy James's live streams expecto
ghost it's the same way dude it's the
same way James like I actually got the
inspiration to get back into live
streaming from watching James and seeing
how he interacts with you guys and and
just how awesome of how how much I love
being in the chat
I was like dude I gotta bring this back
I gotta do this again and so I did but
James is always so well prepared man
he's got topics he's got like his little
uh segments and he's got the transitions
into each one and I was like dude this
is super polished then every time I
watch streams
chat inevitably just like takes him on a
journey and now I think I think he
started doing less of it now of like
just like why dude why even why even you
could you could prepare just like two or
three topics and that's probably gonna
be enough to carry through the stream it
really is new with another uh Super Chat
breaking news we haven't started talking
about Hogwarts Legacy right we haven't
even gotten to the Hogwarts Legacy stuff
yet
Dustin says I thought this was real new
right dude I mean I thought people would
like want to hear about the I mean we
got updates over here we got some new
things over here dude come on now
come on we got like a room rearrangement
we talk about the shirt like
talk about mispronouncing words I
thought this was the content you guys
were interested in
fire tea hey what's up fire I remember
watching video in Harry Potter once and
the person pronounced McGonagall as Mac
Mackinac
wow I mean I'm not gonna
I try not to be one of those people that
gets
I'll I'll say like I'll go on Twitter
and say like hey this is how this is
pronounced or I'll talk about it in my
videos but I don't like to go out of my
way
and correct other people that's just
weird except
okay I take it back a little bit there
there's one that that really gets me
and it's when
and so people say Rowling instead of
rolling
I'm just like guys if if a billionaire
can't get their name pronounced right
then there's probably I mean
this this was solved years ago
uh Melissa Nelly of the Leaky cauldron
she had this thing where she said it's
rolling like bowling because she did a
lot of Harry Potter interviews and stuff
about the fandom and they would always I
think she she would correct people who
would always say Rowling
it's rolling rolling like bowling just
remember it go with it roll with it
that's it
this drives me so nuts yeah that bugs me
yes says Ashley yeah okay so that's
that's the one I'm done I'm done the
others you know I was I read the books
at such a young age that I mean I'll
confess this I'm old enough I'm
confident enough to tell you guys
hold on we we need to mute the music for
this because you got you guys need to
hear me loud and clear
um you know I was in the sixth uh I
think sixth grade yeah when I first read
don't be pulling out your calculators
trying to figure out my age you know
and uh yeah you know I'm an American kid
a lot of these names I don't recognize
so Hermione like okay I'm just gonna
sound it out Herm okay Herm we got Herm
here and then we got one at the end so
is it like her my one or is it hermi one
I say Okay a Hermie one you know that's
hermy one we're going with Hermie one
I kid you not that that one that one was
a very popular one though I feel like a
lot of people got that wrong and so much
so that rolling kind of poked a little
bit of fun at it in uh
Goblet of Fire because then Chrome can't
say it so she actually sounds that one
out in the book so people can see
this is how it's pronounced but
I don't want to digress too much on the
pronunciation stuff Hermione Kenobi
hermy one Kenobi yeah yeah exactly
oh how does he pronounce that feathers
because okay you guys the comments did
it so I'm going in this direction that
is one that was in the people have heard
me if you're regular you've heard me
talk about this before Scholastic had a
Harry Potter pronunciation guide very
early in the life of the series I'm
talking very early
and the original pronunciation
of accio was Osseo
it was Osseo
Axia okay so axio yeah I remember that
was another one uh that a lot of people
said too
axio and then the movies for whatever
the the Scholastic pronunciation
pronunciation was Osseo then the
audiobook obviously for the Stephen Fry
version said it that way then the movies
they they chose Akio so you know what
I'm close man I'm close to doubling down
on ourors
I'm close I'm close
one of my friends said I should just
totally double down on it and now like
and just intentionally go out of my way
in every video to mention auror
and just say it like that
oh man it's all in good fun though it's
all in good fun Reddit as Osseo yeah
ashio
Oh Ellen that's right the dog trainer a
have a good night Owen
and thanks so much for the gifteds
I wonder if the Ravenclaw campaigning
gonna be a spoiler or perhaps might have
a familiar name I'm kind of lean at
first I was thinking it wasn't going to
be a big deal
but the longer it goes on now I'm
thinking maybe it will be a familiar
name
yeah Voldemort rolling says she still
pronounces that as Voldemort but she
knows she says she knows she's the only
one who does that
but the biggest one is uh the one that
people always
really triggers people is when I say
knuts
that one really triggers people
because they're like oh my gosh dude it
is nuts you're embarrassing me
I'm like actually
it's not nuts no matter how you want to
pronounce it because there is an
official Wizarding World website has a
guide out now and it's cut nuts
cut nuts but again that original
Scholastic guide said knuts believe me
or not it's up to you all right let's
get into the news guys let's get into
the news because we have actually had
quite a bit of Hogwarts Legacy news over
the past couple of days none today I saw
some people uh who were here early
talking about do we have anything today
no we did not have anything today
but the past couple days leading up to
it we did so if you didn't follow all
the news last week they started off with
a series of Instagram posts and we were
like why are they just what is this
Instagram exclusivity now come on come
on the K is not silent it's actually not
silent yeah so the current Wizarding
World uh pronunciation is canutz knuts
and that's how the I know for sure
that's how Jim Dale says it in the
audiobooks as well but yeah if you uh
just go on Google for anybody who wants
to go down this Rabbit Hole go on Google
and search for um Wizarding World words
you're mispronouncing or Wizarding World
words mispronounced and there's like a
whole article on it they made an article
about that can't believe it's not silent
I know right
nuts like night yeah that's what a lot
of people thought is that it's the case
silent but nope it's not it's canutz
cannuts guys cannot sickles and galleons
yeah
audiobook changed everything for me
right yeah
eye-opening for a lot of different like
oh wow that's how it's supposed to be
pronouncing this this whole time
so basically they posted all this on
Instagram and then it culminated with a
big post at the end which they shared on
Twitter
so this right here was shared on Twitter
September 30th and it is a one minute 21
second video I'm just gonna go ahead and
let the whole thing play because I even
if you've already seen this let's just
take a moment here to appreciate the
music make sure this is turned up so you
guys can hear this loud and clear
because the music oh so good man
so good so we have an unauthorized guide
to Hogwarts more on that in a second
because there was a lot of
misconceptions on that common room
secrets tip number one
[Music]
don't tap on the glass so they kind of
give us that little tease hey
something's gonna happen if you do this
already seen that right there but
showing that you can interact with items
in the houses
Restricted Section how about that we can
sneak around confirmed that's tip number
two
defense against the dark arts classroom
classroom was made for mischief
we got the spells in the top right
corner there
don't worry we're gonna go through all
these I think everybody knows about
these but then we're getting ready to
transition to the newest ones
so peeves was tip number four
there's there there's the auror
the aura badge we got zonkos there tip
number six so that's and then here's a
new shot which look at this look at this
look at this
something that I noticed here why
are the robes they're not house robes
they're not house robes from what we can
see
so we'll talk more about that in a
second about what that can mean it could
just be a very simple cosmetic thing and
that's it that could be it
[Music]
but it could be more
all right then we got forbidden for a
sneak off in the Forbidden Forest and
live to tell the tale all right what I
love about these is they're two of the
things that people been asking for for a
long time for a long time is uh people
have wanted to know about sneaking
around like can't we sneak around after
hours can we go around the castle
so not only do they tell us any other
tip that we're gonna be able to sneak
around the Restricted Section
now they also say sneak off into the
Forbidden Forest Live to Tell the tale
you gotta love it man you gotta love it
that's tip number seven
and that's the final one
so there was that that was all last week
so the I'm pretty sure that was a Friday
the 30th
let me double check here on the calendar
yeah so September 30th was a Friday
everything culminated with that post
then however they weren't done because
on Monday of this week which made us all
get extra excited because we thought
there was going to be a completely
complete week of new content and then
Tuesday sad face we didn't get anything
new I think people were hoping that each
day we were going to have a new uh
companion showing each day
how are you Tabby just became a channel
member hopefully I didn't mispronounce
that if I did my apologies if you've
been hanging out here for a bit though
you've probably heard you know there's
some pronunciation issues that we have
every now and then thank you so much for
becoming a channel member enjoy those
new Emoji here
all right let me look through the chat
here see what you guys think about the
uh
Olimar yes that's another thing Bogarts
basically confirmed otherwise why would
you have ridiculous in the game right
they do have some really good music star
Hopper it's got me hyped I I know that
was something that a lot of people
wanted to be really strong is the music
because Jeremy Soleil is that how you
say his last name Soul maybe it's soul I
say Soleil Soul Jeremy soul
forgive me if it's wrong
Jeremy
with an S the composer on the old
Hogwarts games
Soul okay there you go
so lay sounds so much like Jeremy Soleil
okay fine Jeremy Soul all right you guys
win
you guys win
I wonder if you can hit enemies with
zonko's items right that's the next big
question right is like how much are they
gonna factor in so here's the one that
just hit on Monday
Sebastian sallow Slytherin and I saw
some people earlier earlier in the chat
talking about one of the other
companions gonna get some love and I
agree I agree Ravenclaw companion aside
I mean I appreciate their Sebastian's
getting a lot of love but
I mean he he had a whole trailer
dedicated to him pretty much we have
seen a lot of Sebastian they they talk
about Sebastian and bring him up a lot
so I don't know if they're gonna give
all of them this kind of love or if they
said you know what let's just focus on
one
because this may be a controversial
opinion here
but I think this stuff right here
and I hate to complain about information
because we went so long without getting
anything at all so I don't I'm not even
complaining it's almost just more of a
an observation for me is this is almost
getting into the territory of like two
months like I don't the story stuff I
really want a lot of that to be kept
Under Wraps
I I honestly wish we like I wish we
hadn't known that Sebastian was a twin
going in
so like right here at the bottom let's
just go ahead and read this so this is
the little uh I love the design on this
by the way which this design made me
instantly think oh there's no way
they're not doing more of these because
this design is clearly ready made for
you to plug in other characters in there
so like character cards whatever we want
to call them here so Sebastian is a
charming and extroverted boy whose Twin
Sister Anne suffers from a mysterious
debilitating curse Sebastian is
convinced that her last hope for a cure
lies in the dark arts and he is
determined to find it so we've already
seen that trailer you know the dark arts
trailer where they talk about that but
then we get two pretty big pieces of
information here they're twins for one
and then also her name is Anne so we did
not know either of those things and then
just another kind of reinforcement on
this curse deal here which
starting to see a lot of thoughts and
speculation in the Phantom uh even
before this actually people were
thinking like a blood maledictus which I
think is seeming even more likely also
some talk is maybe an obscurial as well
yeah Timothy that was this was new so
this was just Monday that they put put
this out right here so Sebastian and his
sister Ann are twins yeah
and from what we can see in the trailer
expecto go was talking about this in his
video because we see her but it doesn't
look like
she is attending Hogwarts
it doesn't look like it because she I
mean again there's a lot of clothing
customization in the game so maybe she
just wasn't in her robes the time but
we'll go look at it here we'll go look
at it I just wanted to kind of catch
everybody up
so that's that's that's it you know
that's all the big news we're fully up
to speed here now we can really dive in
here uh and kind of break this down oh
oh oh I did forget one thing I did
forget one thing and then I'll I'll go
back and read your comments I promise I
just want to get to this one because
this one I think is one that people
could have missed and I'm gonna talk
about this in my video that's hitting
tomorrow on the channel so be ready for
that but this right here so this was the
trailer
and they were kind of building up the
name of this thing right the name of
this book uh this book right here so we
were all speculating we saw like an
authorized guy but then they say
unauthorized guide and so then the way
they have handwriting
all of us were kind of taking that as oh
this is going to be sort of like a
Half-Blood Prince thing to where we get
this book and then there's notes from a
former student in there
that doesn't seem like the case now and
here's why so they're calling it The
Field Guide for one but then in the
comments so somebody asked Chandler it
was a pink Ravenclaw oh did I actually
just
okay right here pink Ravenclaw asked
because the way this is worded right
here
it's like wait Field Guide or authorized
guide are they two different books so
that's what they ask right here wait is
the unauthorized guide the field guide
or these two distinct books so then
Chandler writes and says the
unauthorized guide is our fun social
spin on things a fun way to show you a
variety of things around Hogwarts via
our social channels the field guide is
in game with more details about it yet
to be revealed so I want to see what you
guys think on this because from the from
his answer there I think that means the
tips
aren't actually in the field guide
which is a little bit confusing but then
I'm like okay maybe the tips are still
in there but not the little handwritten
pieces
I think he what he is saying here is
that oh that was just kind of our fun
way as a social media as a marketing
team of saying Hey look
we're acting like you know it's like the
Half Blood Prince book so I'm thinking
from again based on based on Chandler's
response right here I'm thinking that
all they really have told us so far is
the field guide like here's the name of
the book it's the field guide now the
tips
are just just like a fun social media
thing
just a fun social media thing
that's what I'm that's what I'm thinking
hey we got Amir in the house as well I
see Mary Studios Mary fed it and shout
you out already Paddy foot is here
amazing cjb blood curse nagini relation
probably way well definitely way too
early in the timeline
for nagini
yeah way too early for that we got
Jaguar gaming here what if they hype us
up for one specific house companion so
we don't know with you that that's
another good point Jaguar that's another
good point so I I thought about that too
like maybe they're just they're gonna
show things on Sebastian and everybody
else has kept Under Wraps
because I I do feel like it's kind of
starting to Teeter in that direction of
I'm starting to feel like we're getting
we're getting a little bit too much
getting a little bit too much
obscurios are not a curse right right
Moon yeah
[Music]
fire why do you think we haven't gotten
a detailed look at combat yet uh I think
it's coming
I think it's coming yep
hey 300 people in here Shadow guide says
let's go
welcome guys if it's your first time
here thanks for hanging out feel free to
jump in the chat say hello or sit back
relax you can you can lurk and enjoy the
Stream Shadow and Poppy is a dark wizard
what I'm dude
that is a new I have not heard that
theory
poppy dark wizard
nah that's why they're keeping poppy
Under Wraps dude they can't say anything
they don't want us to get any more hints
for the second tip you can see the rest
of the text at the top when it
transitions yeah exactly Levi which we
couldn't before
but yeah fire I think I think the combat
breakdown is definitely coming
definitely coming
if we can get detention does the
detention where we get hung by our
thumbs exist during these times I know
philcha and his shame they let the old
punishments die
I thought about that the other day I
read
I can't remember when I thought about
that I feel like either I read a section
of the book or
saw a quote in a video or something
but I remembered that line from
from filch
I'm gonna cut down the music just
a touch there just a little bit
but I also have this pulled up here we
can talk about the the maledictus
I saw Jake was here in the house as well
Jake how's it going dude welcome
heard vampires a rumor do you know
anything about that so the vampire thing
let's go back
to the video here
the vampire thing I'm not gonna say
they're not in but what a lot of people
were using it to base it on was
this right here
because we saw garlic so in the in the
Instagram post the top part here was cut
off we couldn't see the top part now we
can see the top part which reveals bring
flowers to garlic with a capital G and a
K on the end so it would appear that
garlic is the name of someone student
Professor maybe a librarian
uh and then it says make sure they're
not and a lot of people think this says
wilted right here
bring flowers to garlic make sure
they're not wilted so a lot of people
were jumping on that and thinking that
meant vampires were in the game so I'm
not gonna say vampires are not in the
game but that recent kind of spring up
of the rumor was based around this which
is now not what we had previously
thought
not what we thought before
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what if there's famous Witcher wizard
cards from chocolate frogs for a
collection that's one that I like
wouldn't mind if they break Canon
it's chocolate frog cards are not
supposed to be around we've actually
already seen a box of chocolate frog
cards though
in game in the Gameplay trailer
[Music]
so
I I hope they can come up with maybe a
clever way around it but I just
honestly I wouldn't mind if they just
said you know what in our game they were
invented earlier I I love the they're
just such a great collectible they
really are such a great collectible
[Music]
in the Gameplay trailer you thought
Sebastian's sister was his mother
could we be an animagus okay speaking of
pronunciation that's another one that
if you look at the Muggle net guide
animagus is how that's what's on there
but you can't win I say animages people
say no I say animagus people say no
say animeji
people say no
animation see I always say animages
because we say in a magi we don't say
animal guy
and a magi
tips are just promos yeah seems that way
maybe garlic is a house self
I like that careless dreamer I like that
I did not think about that one yet I
think a lot of people were thinking
maybe that okay they're talking about
restrict Restricted Section of the
library maybe it's the librarian because
she looks pretty upset in the trailer
maybe it's her
yeah so that's where the vampire thing
came from who names their child garlic
well it's it's last name garlic so
oh but yeah how self
to me garlic
that that would go well much more with a
house elf I feel like yeah
Arkham Knight welcome thinking 50 plus
gameplay
talking about hours maybe
what if poppy is the one who teaches us
Avada Kedavra
imagine
they are James they are still taunting
poppy indeed people feel still still
think Poppy's behind it all
hey Mark welcome how's it going
three Channel member is back with us
once again as well
Levi everything we know so far about the
game looks like a lot in the game how
big will the game be yeah it's
I mean let's talk about this one right
here
it's the one where it talks about the
cauldron cakes
we'll talk we need to go back and talk
about the Spells briefly too but
right here
[Music]
so
Twitter's not letting me hide this
section right here but cauldron cakes
batter is moist good to trade with
what what made me think of this is you
saying like how big is this game
we it seems like we find out about some
new super in-depth system
all the time like and I shouldn't say
super in depth we have no idea the depth
of this of this trading system but the
fact that like we can trade this stuff
with
seemingly other characters or maybe the
shopkeepers is all they're talking about
it's just like every time we learn
something new there's there's another
layer that we get to this game that we
didn't have before then it talks about
fizzing wisbees
uh then we have pepperimps up here
and then the one before it
uh let's see not the ore badge but the
the one with the Spells right here
[Music]
Arkham Knight waiting for the Ravenclaw
companion I know dude I know
I feel like that we'll definitely get
the a Ravenclaw companion that would
just be super strange if they had one
for every house and not Ravenclaw I mean
initially we were even wondering is
there going to be more than one house
I'm starting to lean toward no on that
and I'm thinking just one per house but
who knows
who knows
[Music]
oh instant Darkness powder would be cool
in zonko's
tips are hidden items or cheat or an
intro to a quest yeah I could see that
being if there's any loading screens I
could see the tips being part of the
loading screen yeah but for much
Chandler was saying it sounds like it's
definitely just a social media thing
foreign
poppy is an obscure calling it now
oh my gosh peeves rocking that 19th
century clown drip I know don't you love
his hat
[Music]
I love peeves's hat
and he's just like juggling the I think
these are the
the beater bats
for Quidditch
that he has on fire the Twitter
compression man just oh it just kills
this so much
makes it so blurry so sorry my my
apologies for that nothing I can do
unfortunately I don't think that they
didn't post this one on YouTube so we
can't get a
higher quality one of it dude why is my
this is like worrying me every time I
move this this feels
really really loose and I don't know why
should not be that loose we'll figure it
out
another time as long as it doesn't fall
right here
I think we're good
Harry Potter will use a Time Turner oh
my gosh I hope not no time I would be
totally fine with zero time Turners just
don't even go there don't
oh my gosh then they're gonna have us
like time traveling into the Battle of
Hogwarts like we were there all along
no just no
don't do it
why are we trading batter uh good
question
good question
uh Jake two days left two days left for
what no I didn't see that
yo Noob with another Super Chat
poppy final boss of the game don't
forget to hydrate hey thank you for the
Super Chat and thank you for the
hydration reminder
tonight we've got a Cherry Coke Zero
here you go I always like to just uh you
know show off the
not sponsored not sponsored just show
off the can
I've gotten to where every time I
drink any canned beverage I just I
always use the Cozy now
it just it it really seems to make a big
difference
and another Super Chat coming in from
zootera
zutara babe09
I probably botched that really bad
really bad zutara
if I got that right thank you so much
for the Super Chat very much appreciated
thank you for supporting the channel I
was re-watching some of your old Chamber
of Secrets Let's Plays and you mentioned
a theory about herpo the foul yeah yeah
yeah do you still think he'll be in the
game at all
so I made a video about that one too
that was a theory that
I want to say it popped up in one of
those leaks
most likely a fake leak
but the theory let me see if I can
remember it was basically that
so herbal the foul for those of you
don't know is
uh in in the lore in the Canon of Harry
Potter is supposedly the first person
who ever created a horcrux actually you
know what we're in a great spot
to pull this up
we are on Harry Potter lexicon right
here
and he's been on a wizard card so
herpell the foul who's perhaps the
original Evil wizard in history is the
first to create a horcrux successfully
he created only one horcrux Voldemort
was the first to split his soul multiple
times so he was born before 100 A.D
so we're talking this dude was ancient I
mean he's really really old
here's another bit of artwork that they
have
I love the artwork that they have all
kinds of artwork on
on the uh Harry Potter lexicons like
this one here's the uh artist right here
so he was also a parcel mouth so he
could control the Great Serpent which
lived for 900 years also the first
wizard to successfully create a horcrux
now here's the big question whether
herpo the foul survived trying to make a
horcrux or how long he survived because
of his horcrux is Left To The Mists of
ancient history but
the JK Rowling has said many Wizards
have tried to create one and neither
succeeded nor survived
so that's where they actually have a
little bit of wiggle room to play around
in the cannon they could have herpo the
foul be the main villain they could
and have him have survived all this time
thanks to
a horcrux
it would just be a single horcrux though
so I mean honestly I wouldn't hate it I
wouldn't hate it I I would
I think it could be done well I do but
as far as do I still think he'll be in
the game it was just one of those random
theories that people had so I don't know
if
I don't know that I would say it's
likely I I have felt for a long time
that
I think they're gonna try to carve their
kind of own path with this game
especially when it comes to the story
that's why I never really felt strongly
that Dumbledore would be in I'm just
like he's just such a key character to
the main series and even to the spin-off
fantastic Beast series that I think they
want it to be
their own characters with some side
names that we'll recognize like
Weasley's like Malfoy's like blacks
things like that so
we shall see but yeah I wouldn't hate it
I think I think it could be uh done very
well
thank you so much for the Super Chat
once again Ravenclaw Tyrell there's so
much they are telling us yeah we're
getting a lot because we went from such
a drought of getting nothing and now
just
we're getting spoiled now I think that's
why people were so upset today because
after yesterday I was like oh dude okay
we're starting with this drop on
Sebastian Monday so we gotta get
something new every day this week let's
go
channel is like not so fast not so fast
yeah I agree Mary it would be very
strange if Ravenclaw didn't can't wait
to play Gotham Knights on PS5
Nathan been playing OverWatch 2 how is
it dude how is it
nice product I know right
oh I shouldn't do that unless they're
paying me something right
why do I why do I feel the need also uh
uplift deaths guys that's the desk I
have
James drink my casual coffee
only thing oh I'm not a big coffee
drinker my wife is my wife drinks a lot
of coffee Nicholas Flamel hey that's
another one that could be he definitely
could be
[Music]
Triwizard DLC possibly that's another
one that is unlikely because the
tri-wizard tournament would have been
ended by that point because they are
they had a big disastrous one now the
the way they could work it in
is it was said even in the lore that
there were several attempts to bring
back the tri-wizard tournament but they
failed
so if they try to do it they would just
have to make it to where it fails for
whatever reason or people decide okay no
we're not gonna keep doing this
[Music]
Skyline says I was thinking the ancient
magic might have something to do with
time travel oh
I mean I don't I don't hate time travel
it's just so hard to do well
and I'm just I don't know man like
to me when time travel is possible
anything's possible
and because people die time travel for
me and stories it always reduces the
stakes
because it's like no matter how you
choose to do time travel whether you
have like a splitting off of the
universe to where it's like okay by me
going back in time I'm actually creating
a new reality
which I
that's why I'm struggling to kind of get
into the whole the new era of Marvel
with like this whole Multiverse thing
like don't get me wrong it could be done
well like a great example is a
oh my gosh
the Spider-Man movie
that did this so well
not the newest one the one with um
oh my gosh why can I not think of this
why can I not think of this
Spider-Man
um animated movie what is that movie
called dude
into the spider-verse there we go
you guys probably already said it in the
chat yeah Gabe got it nah not no way
home not no way home into the
spider-verse the one I was thinking of
it can be done well but I just uh
it's my issue with cursed child one of
my big issues with cursed child is how
they just completely
rewrite the rules of the Harry Potter of
how time travel is supposed to work in
Harry Potter they completely rewrite the
rules
I was okay with the imprison Nebraska
Azkaban because when you do time travel
that's how I like it to be done it's
called a closed loop there's a closed
loop so there's no second reality
there's no like 500 other runs that just
got created when Harry and Ron shoot or
no actually Hermione when Harry and
Hermione choose to go back in time no
it's a closed loop they always went back
in time and that's why it happens
when that that moment in the book in
book three when we hear the
ax chop down and they think it was
Buckbeak no Buckbeak was never killed
because it always had to happen that way
it was a closed loop oh I could I could
rant on time travel for a while but when
you start getting into all these like
splitting of realities it's like okay
well that
that Harry Potter died but there's like
500 other Harry Potter so
okay go tell me a story about it's just
like oh it lowers the stakes for me when
I'm when I'm in stories that have a lot
of time travel
Arkham Knight says I'd rather not be
time travel too much complexity yeah
yeah it really takes a lot to do it
right
takes a lot to do it right
Days of Future Past I did see that one
it's been so long and I only watched it
once but I do remember liking that too
yeah
I do remember liking that
going kept dying right yeah and the
tribe was attorneys
they kept not going well
oh I like this question from Theo here
do you think the Sebastian storyline was
the original main story for our
character just basing it off Reddit
Rumors in 2018 when the game was called
Hogwarts A Dark Legacy
I don't know if it's so much that that
was the original plan for the main story
or if that leak happened as a result of
people getting wind
maybe somebody knew about that side
quest
and they just kind of took it and ran
with it I don't know but that's an
interesting question for sure
because the more we're learning about
these Side Stories I mean just let's
think about the Sebastian one
this is a an optional thing you guys
an optional thing chandlerwood has
already confirmed the quest that we see
in the trailer
let me pull this up here
so Hogwarts Legacy dark arts trailer
this one right here
they confirm that this is optional
so optional so this whole deal with
Sebastian and his sister and looking for
a cure and they're not being a cure he
believes that the Cure is somehow
related to the dark arts the dark arts
are somehow going to lead him to the
Cure that's all side mission
[Music]
mind-blowing which earlier I said I'm
kind of I kind of feel like they're
showing a little bit too much on story
but to be fair very little of the of the
main story so most of what we have seen
is from is from the side story so that I
do applaud them for that hopefully they
don't I don't want them to spoil
everything in on the story real honestly
like all I need to see is I need to see
some gameplay need to see some gameplay
with some combat and then I want to know
how the classes and the time system
works that is it like once once we get
that I'm good I'm good I won't need
anything else hey Levi thanks for
hanging out dude have a good night
the ancient power will be a family
bloodline curse I think so I think the
curse I think the bloodline curse will
be Sebastian's sister and then our
ancient magic will be separate from that
tied to our past whether it's Merlin or
some other ancient wizard
something to do with maybe our bloodline
yeah but I don't I don't think it's
related to the uh
to a curse or anything but yeah I guess
I could see you said bloodline too
that's why I was double checking her
comment I could see bloodline
starhop are not a fan of time travel hey
I'm with you
Jaguar excited to see how the Hogs mean
any other shop works if we have to clean
up get the product set up right
JKR didn't write cursed child not can't
I know I refuse even though she like
I mean she she considers it Cannon which
I'm just like
how how they even put like the freaking
eighth that's the thing that gets me it
I would have been totally fine if
they're just like oh this is a a fun
kind of what if Harry Potter story and
we're we're writing it for a play
audience because I've heard the play
like as a play it's actually really good
if it was some like
alternate Dimension possibility thing
I'm good with that but like saying the
eighth book like saying that oh no no no
no no no no
can't go there
new time yeah that that's how they got
around it got around it Elizabeth is by
saying that oh dude and I missed uh Oni
savior two months hey let's go Oni
savior thank you so much sorry I haven't
been around just got back from Poland
wow
hope you had some fun travels
welcome back though only savior good to
see you here and thank you for your
support on the channel
maybe we'll see a hand of Glory in game
and interact with it
uh playing Batgirl this game looks like
fun
oh you talk about in uh
this suit right here are you talking
about the Gotham game
[Music]
time traveling and touching something at
the end of the world right
looks like a lot of folks agreeing with
time travel
and how uh difficult it is to pull off
yeah that's right starhopper yep they
even called the trailer
right there Sebastian's Dark Legacy
optional is just another uh another for
do it before the main store yeah yeah
yeah you know we're all gonna do it
we're all gonna do it
uh Jake can you do a kahoot all about
Hogwarts Legacy or Hogwarts it would be
fun what's what's kahoot
I know my son was doing some things with
that for like some kind of math game for
school but I that's that's like all I I
thought it was a
uh get like a little kids game that's
all I knew about it hey Arkham Knight
thanks for hanging out have a good one
[Music]
if we assume Bogarts are in the game
what form do you think they'll take will
it be dynamic same for everyone I think
same for everyone
and I also think that's how they will
handle Patronus
if it's in if it's in I think it's in
and I think it will be based on our
character's past that's how they'll kind
of get around it
but yeah Patronus or I'm sorry Bogart
seemingly confirmed because that's what
I had pulled up and then we got off on
another topic here this shot right here
we can see what is most likely
petrificus totalus Rick to simpra
ridiculous and stupefy so why I mean
ridiculous is not going to be in there
unless there are Bogarts in the game
[Music]
all right so I wanted to talk about this
uh we were talking about the curse and
what it could possibly be
so I want to talk about this maledictus
because I myself haven't reviewed this
in a while I know it was nagini and I
know it was something that we didn't
really learn about until like see right
here when they've got CC that's citing
cursed child
CC cursed child
CG is crimes of Grindelwald CG crimes of
Grindelwald so I honestly I prefer using
more the crimes of Grindelwald stuff
opposed to Cursed child but we'll look
at that too
foreign
[Music]
guys you are severely
underestimating my age
[Music]
oh yeah this is the thing that my
this is the thing that my son had to log
into he's in third grade
to play like math games and stuff
[Music]
create your own kahoot for free at
kahoot.com
so it's like a learning tool okay
yeah dude back back in my day
we we did not have cahoots
dude
we played the Oregon Trail Jake
you you Google up the Oregon Trail my
friend
that's what we learned on back in the
day
cookies no I don't want your cookies
reject all okay
sign up for free kahoot delivers
engaging learning to billions
all right so I knew what it was I just
didn't know that apparently a lot of
people use it for
love the Oregon Trail right
OG Oregon Trail man oh my gosh
I love the one when they added the first
person mode to the hunting oh my gosh
that was when it got really cool first
person hunting
the best day we got
died of dysentery oh yeah
that's how I know what a cona Conestoga
wagon is let's see if I've been
mispronouncing that all the all these
years
[Music]
let's see let's see
Conestoga wagon nope nailed it
there you go straight from Webster if
you guys say that's wrong
numbers muncher oh yes okay now you guys
are talking my speed here we go here we
go all the 90s kids rising up we're all
like dude what the heck is a kahoot man
what the heck is code
oh that's funny
yeah Math Blaster
that was a real popular one too
Yeet is in the dictionary what when did
that get added
well Hogwarts Legacy have a Conestoga
wagon hey new video idea that get like
10 views
will Hogwarts Legacy have a Conestoga
wagon
all right all right all right let's read
about this maledictus here so
this uh whole thing with Sebastian and
his sister debilitating curse
a lot of speculation going around that
it's maledictus so let's go and order
first
ah looks like we have to just read it
straight through but if you look at the
parentheses here that's where they're
getting their citations from so
HP Lex is gone here guys a maledictus is
a witch or wizard who suffers from a
blood curse
one form of this Affliction referred to
as a malediction had been inherited by
Draco Malfoy's wife Astoria Greengrass
Astoria died from the blood curse in
August of 2019. so this bit here is like
cursed child
now this is the one that most people are
more familiar with because of the movies
The Fantastic Beasts movies another form
causes its victim to slowly transform
permanently into a beast
a maledictus was the feature Act of the
circus Arc arcanus arcanus the highlight
of the Act was when a girl nagini melts
into coils transforming herself into a
huge snake
so for any of you who didn't watch the
Fantastic Beasts movies yes it turns out
nagini was once human
foreign
unfortunately it didn't really end up
being that big of a deal in the
Fantastic Beasts movies I think when a
lot of people first saw it they thought
it was going to be
a little bit more significant than it
was
but here's when it when people first
started speculating right here
this actually came out before the movie
this little uh
kind of a circus
advertisement right here and this
section right here the enchanted snake
girl alive beguiling mesmerizing
I think this is highly likely
I'll I'll say that I think it's highly
likely
another reason I think it's highly
likely is because of how much of an
emphasis they have placed on
uh magical creatures and Beasts for this
that's why I think it is looking pretty
likely they have placed such a big
emphasis
on the carrying of magical creatures
and the poachers which is something that
we talked about in a couple of videos
before before we started getting more
information about the game so I could I
could definitely see that and it just
adds like another layer to the magical
creatures like if
if she's already starting to transform
because from the way let me read this
again
well yeah because like in the movies
nagini can she can go back and forth
she's not stuck yet but eventually
they'll be able to
um they won't be able to to transform
back into human form
turn 30 on Friday feel older every day
jay Rossi said feeling ancient
nah age it's just a number guys just a
number
we'll just have to you know Google the
kahoots
and get familiar with it
it's all good
Jaguar gamer says the thing almost no
one talks about is when you make a
Wizarding World account or anything you
never choose what blood you are
yeah why
okay here's my question on that Jaguar
why are people so interested in that
because honestly like I
I just never like understood the appeal
it's never mattered to me to like get to
pick that
but I don't I mean I don't want to make
you feel like you're definitely not
alone like I get that question a lot
people ask like do you think we'll be
able to choose our blood status at the
start of the game
and I I don't know I just I guess I
don't get why
I mean like what I guess what would it
affect
if you choose muggleborn you might get I
mean is that going to make people be
like hateful to you because this game is
in a much older time and even if the
Headmaster is Phineas black
he did not even like allowing Muggles
into the school
would it change something like that or
I I guess like I just don't see how it
would really impact things but again
you're not the only one a lot of people
seem to want that so
I kind of feel like they'll it will be
set for us I think it will be based on
whatever backstory they have come up
with for our character and it could be
significant it could be
my money is on Half Blood for our
character though
if if it is set I think it's I think
it's most likely half blood
[Music]
kid picks 3D was the kid intro to
photoshop oh I don't think I remember
I remember doing one that was like Corel
oh man it was like Corel with all these
crayons
I cannot remember the name of it
Nathan wonder who would have more
viewers if retro and James stream dude I
I would I wouldn't want to stream at the
same time as James because I don't want
to make I know we have so many of the
same audience I wouldn't want to make
anybody choose
that's why I don't pick that's why I
chose Tuesday instead of Wednesday
for my live streams
I want to have James on at some point I
want to start doing
[Music]
the problem like if I have when I have
James on because I definitely want to
have him on I feel like
I know how he and I like I can just tell
how much he likes to
Theory craft and how much he really gets
into it we would just like we would just
go man we would just we could talk all
night I have no doubts about that
yeah I think a lot of cadaver as a
finisher I do I don't think it's
something we'll be able to spam at all
times
just a guess but I think uh I think an
educated guess based on what we've seen
[Music]
Mary says I too have never cared hey
Marcus nice to meet you as well
have you ever seen the worst witch I
love how I take
uh
I'm not following that comment Rob
I love how I take the Mickey our
technology
a lot of Technology yeah I'm not
following that one
oh my gosh Rossi can you imagine dude
like one once she's if she permanently
oh if she permanently transforms
oh my gosh
Niraj retro saving Tuesday hey Niraj
thank you I hope you're hope I'm making
your night a little bit better
let's status was the whole point of
ultimate story yeah yeah that's true it
was a big part of what Voldemort was
doing
but it's like they couldn't
unless they make it unless they make it
set
they couldn't make it a key part of the
story
if they make it set then it could factor
in yeah
blood status might determine how certain
people react yeah that's like the only
thing I could think of but
I just don't know if they would want to
go down that road man like that just
that gets kind of awkward like if you
choose muggleborn and then they program
characters in there who are
making jeers and comments at you as you
walk by
[Music]
I don't know I don't know
or if it comes into play for some sort
of
Story related reason but then back to
what I was saying it would have to be
tied to your
it has to be the same for all of us
Levi I think you finally know oh my gosh
are you going to the dark side Levi are
you going Slytherin
yeah I feel like half blood Jenna that's
my guess too Mary thinks half blood or
pure blood
if bloodline choice is an option
pureblood will be balanced in all magic
muggleborn well-versed in defensive
magic Half Blood well versed in
offensive
now that's an interesting idea I don't
know that there's much Cannon to back
that up but
if they made it tied into stats somehow
Jaguar says I'm confused on the story
perspective due to how we can manipulate
ancient magic okay gotcha so if we were
muggleborn it was once in a lifetime but
with gotcha okay now for that reason
yeah I can I can see how it would be
important for that for sure and that's I
mean that's the question they gotta
answer right
that's the question they have to answer
why do we have this ancient magic why is
it only us why is it taken until we were
fifth year or whatever to manifest
itself
they gotta answer all those things and I
I think they will
they want us to be speculating I mean
they
they've highlighted why that that is a
question we need to be asking what did
your character survive you know
laughs
yep
[Music]
Gabe I think that being half blood has
to do with us starting fifth year
Timothy my sister wants to wants to AKA
everyone in the school should I be
concerned uh not concerned maybe a
little bit maybe a little bit but she's
not alone she's not she's she's alone
that's a con like that comment
pops up so frequently on my YouTube
videos
frequently I scroll through comments and
like oh yep there's another person who
wants to AK everybody in the school yep
there it there's another one and there's
another one
I don't think it's gonna be
I don't think that's how it's gonna work
which is gonna make some people angry I
think it's gonna be finisher only
I mean realistically if that happened
if that happened I mean the professors
are just going to instantly overtake you
as a
and you would get kicked at it I mean
you you kicked out of school obviously
so maybe there's like a fun Easter egg
where they have where you can it's just
an instant game over screen or something
if you AK a student
DJ and welcome to Jane a don't worry
about the late arrival don't worry we
are indeed having a good night
Shadow and my guess is each companion
will have a side quest Seb is the dark
arts natsai saving creatures from
poachers poppy world domination
that's that's an interesting bit on Nat
side though because Poppy is the one
that we know from the trailer they
outright said like poppy has the
uh she's more interested in magical
creatures than interactive with humans
yet Nat's eyes Quest or I guess we
should say mission
we saw her helping the main character
save the hippogriff that was in the
Autodesk trailer so that's not one
they've released I mean Autodesk has
released it on their YouTube so you guys
can watch it they are the official
version but Hogwarts Legacy hasn't
released that like as its own separate
trailer or anything
but yeah that's a good that's a good
question
James if Sebastian's sister is a twin
she's in our year yeah if if Sebastian
is in our
do you know what I don't guess we've
ever gotten that confirmed if he is the
same year as us
we would assume so because we see him in
the defense against the dark arts room
so most likely yeah most likely we were
talking earlier though James about is
she even going to school at all because
let's
let's um
let's pull up the trailer here
because there is a
you know the scene where we see her
right here
right oh it was before that
so there's Sebastian sneaking around
which this gives so much more weight to
this scene right like At first your your
first impression of Sebastian is like oh
you know typical Slytherin breaking
rules sneaking around and now they're
introducing this at these extra layers
to him well yeah he is doing that but
actually
he's trying to find a cure for his
sister
and he's dabbling in these dark arts
because he thinks that might be the only
way to save her it puts a totally new
light totally new spin on it
but yeah this shot right here like she
doesn't have on any
robes at all
so maybe she's not even able to go to
school
now she could the game has a lot of
customization when it comes to clothing
maybe she's just maybe she has like a
different curriculum where
there's still a lot of we don't know yet
either if this is their dad
because it almost seems like she is
staying with with him
but if that's their dad why wouldn't he
like wouldn't he want to try everything
he can too but then there's so much we
don't know about him just so many
questions still but yeah so we don't
even know if she's attending school but
you're right they should be the same age
yes
very long answer to that question
yeah that's true as well Rossi rather
have her transform into an animal than
outright die
yeah maybe this could be an example of
a way
I don't know if we know how much nagini
retains her prior memories
like once you fully transform like do
you slowly just become the the Beast or
do you still retain your human memories
and maybe nagini just
went with Voldemort out of you know
anger or frustration hope of maybe him
being able to reverse it I don't know
but it would be interesting if she does
transform and then they show like the
other spin on it like rather than
them transforming into this
Sinister Beast of a snake that goes on
to serve the greatest dark lord
um what if she instead is you know
has a positive spin on it basically but
man I hope oh hopefully we can find a
cure
I hope so
I am uh Gryffindor Levi if you're asking
me
[Music]
if
indoor
how do we study uh well
we don't know yet we know we know that
the extra curriculum
is going to be hold on hold on
right here is what it looks like they're
gonna have not here but right here
they're gonna have these extra
activities for our character to catch up
so like this one they're clearly working
on
I think that's accio it also looks like
Carpe retract them but
so I would assume they're going to have
different little challenges for all of
the spells that we learn
and then we'll probably have the class
itself as well whether that's just a
couple cut scenes or what we'll we'll
see
could be hiding her like they did Ariana
oh what if they were hiding her
[Music]
Dustin I think he's the caretaker I do
but we're not a hundred percent
I mean clearly he is
I feel like he's pretty clearly employed
at Hogwarts and we don't see him up
there with the teachers in any of the
uh the scenes that we get in the Great
Hall
and then it that scene looks like where
he's in there with Sebastian and Anne it
looks like it could be the interior of
like the gamekeeper's hut
Noob with another Super Chat Noob dude
thank you so much for the support on the
Channel with the Super Chat
wait a second did students spawn in the
background
wait wait which C we talking about here
are we talking about the uh
I'll look for your comment you don't
have to Super Chat again
which scene were you talking about for
the uh people spawning in the background
there's a couple of little uh graphical
glitches in the trailer that people have
discovered over time
djane if that is their father maybe
their mother died of the blood curse
right yeah because it's passed down
James was talking about this in his
video today expect to go it's passed
down uh to females
the maladic discurse
supercarlin Brothers had a bit on nagini
I think I remember watching that
shadowing that sounds right I do feel
like I remember seeing a video on that
[Music]
the extra mini game oh okay all right
let's go look at the extra mini game is
what new was talking about there
right
here okay let's watch it once in normal
mode and then we'll slow it down if we
don't catch it
[Music]
or if it's the way that the uh the
camera works when we cast the spell
all right let's slow it down here
foreign
two five speed so noob's talking about
over here in this area so I think they
might be
yeah you could see somebody right there
oh they told those two totally do spawn
in this person we can see the whole time
oh I didn't mean to skip that much
I meant to just go frame yeah look at
that so from here it's right there
the two sitting down over there on the
left
they totally spawn in that's funny
dude how did you catch that
we've seen this trailer so many times it
happened so quick too
it's because it's sort of hidden behind
the
it happens right when the camera shifts
because of the the spell movement
but yeah there's a there's a couple of
little instances like that in the
trailer
right if it's a blood malediction then
there's probably not going to be a cure
because I don't think we've gotten
a cure even by Harry Potter's day
[Music]
Niraj oh see that's kind of their trump
card for everything right the ancient
Magic
that's where they could get around later
Cannon
maybe at the end of the game we choose
to conceal this ancient magic forever
hide it away where no one will ever find
it or somehow we put an end to the
ancient magic yeah so they could use
Ancient magic as a way to rescue her
because who right now who knows
what sort of powers the ancient magic
could hold
[Music]
The Cure is basilisk Venom ooh is that
is that a Canon thing I don't remember
seeing that anywhere but I mean you
could you could definitely be right
could definitely be right
[Music]
oh there's an episode of the worst witch
where they have a Magic Touch like
creedy's camera
and it grants wishes
oh interesting I'm not following the
Creedence camera bit or maybe Colin
creevy
Colin creevey's camera
[Music]
nah I don't think so Jaguar I don't
think it's gonna go that deep
just just a guess I don't think so
that's why it was delayed yeah yeah that
last that last bit of Polish that's
needed
Ashley why do you think they're hiding
the Ravenclaw companion someone with a
name we might recognize
I go back and forth on it Ashley I go
back and forth
for a while I was thinking it was just
simply a
a marketing thing just something for
them to hold back to have like another
fun reveal and I still I still think
that could be the case but I don't know
here lately I'm I'm starting to get
swayed more to the side of believing
that it will end up being
a last name that we recognize
I still like my idea of it being
bethilda bag shot and then the field
guide we're like helping her write the
early versions of Hogwarts of history
but
that was that was purely more fanfic
fanfici than having any kind of uh real
evidence of that being the case
if Sebastian's questline just ends if
you don't cast crucio
so I don't think the only three choices
are
you can
he'll cast it on you
you cast it on him or someone I think we
assume it would be him but some people
are saying no it could be the other oh
my gosh I think there was another I
think I just saw another uh person
teleporting in
[Music]
oh look at this
look at the heck
where did this Goblin come from
oh wait okay dude the Goblin's like he's
right there right now
and then oh and then he just like shifts
up
dude he just wait he just levitated
and then he has like this sort of
greenish glow
we were just talking about how many
times we've watched this trailer and
here we are finding things that we do
look at
look at oh dude that is the corruption
right there on these goblins
look at this man
this like demonic presence
behind the goblin right here
that is crazy
and then right oh there he goes
let's see what happens to him does it
just cut away or does he
no he like
he sort of hovers over to the his right
and then he's gone oh no no he's not
gone he's over here now
that man got speedy recovery
uh this is fig right here Professor fig
[Music]
that's Professor fig there
that man got speedy recovery right for
sure
let's watch the rest of it here
he's just hanging out over there now oh
no dude now looks like he's casting
something did you oh there's there's the
kind of
what is he doing
it looks like he's casting some sort of
healing or some kind of buff spell
hey ether welcome welcome late but here
all good
all good good to see you
James loved the befilled bag shot idea
first I've heard yeah I threw that out
there on Twitter one day it was when
they were hyping up the field guide
before we knew it was called The Field
Guide I was like guys what if
what if the book is Hogwarts A History
because all that they were giving us all
those tips and so I'm thinking these are
all tips that are things we know about
Hogwarts what if we're helping a young
Matilda backshot right
Hogwarts A History
and it it works with the timeline
bathilda we don't know her exact date of
birth
the HP Wiki people are taking it as 100
fact when
let me guess let me just show you guys
here
so bathilda bagshot HP Wiki
you got to be careful with the wiki they
do a good job but they are they
basically pull from everything whereas
HP lexicon
tries to focus a bit more on
sources that are directly from the
author so like directly from JK Rowling
or things JK Rowling has said in in
interviews and chat logs that sort of
thing
so pre-1873
that's really all they are saying about
her her birth
but right here
I wish I'd left my copy I had my copy of
Deathly Hallows down here earlier
uh there's a part that talks about okay
yeah right here right here
in the 1890s bagshot was already an
adult
this right here this is the key part
already an adult living in her house in
godrick's Hollow and Kendra Dumbledore
moved there from the mold on the world
along with her young children Albus
aberforth Ariana after her husband
percival's well-publicized arrests and
imprisonment in Azkaban but they thought
it tried to befriend Kendra after they
arrived but she was rebuffed
okay so people see this already in an
adult right here but you got to look at
the source so their source for this
section right here hit this number nine
and it takes you down here Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows chapter 11 the
bribe
go and read that chapter which is what I
did
and you read that section it says
nothing about bathilda being an adult
nothing at all
says nothing about her appearance where
we could even determine what her age
might be
it just simply says that she tried to go
over and I forgot what it said she was
bringing or doing for the Dumbledore's
and she was basically rebuffed that
that's it
so it could work is it likely no it's
not likely
but it's like I don't know why they say
she was already an adult and again adult
could be 17.
that could be 17 for for British
and she could still be going to Hogwarts
now I will give you that the way that it
the way she talks it seems like she is
close to the same age potentially as
Kendra
but that is purely
an assumption purely an assumption
it never says an adult never says
anything about her age
unless there's another section in that
chapter that I missed because I went
back and read it I was like where are
they pulling this from
and we also don't know her house she did
live in godrick's Hollow so you would
assume Gryffindor but then I started
thinking I was like there's no way that
every single person who lived in godrics
Hollow is a Gryffindor right surely you
can be I mean you could be born there
and not be a Gryffindor
yeah we really just don't know enough
but I think it'd be super fun if we were
helping her write Hogwarts history
I think it's a little bit less likely
now though since we learned that those
tips aren't really part of the
the tips aren't really part of the Field
Guide it seems like
our pets confirmed like owls cats or
toads
not 100 no I think it's almost certain
though because of
this whole Menagerie scene right here in
this trailer
watch when we go into the Menagerie here
coming up
we see a nasal we see a
we see a tiny owl I believe very briefly
and then there's uh there's one more
animal we see in here for sure
[Music]
niffler I believe I think do we see a
niffler in this shot
all right come on Deke come on
I mean because like if they're going to
the level of
doing this right here and then they've
confirmed we'll be nursing magical
creatures back to hell so it's like if
you're gonna have all that in there
where we can nurse creatures back to
health then right here this looks like a
super tiny owl to me like remember uh
Pig Widgeon
foreign
Little Owl right there
then we get the nasal right there and I
mean clearly our character is is brush
excuse me
brushing the nasal
using a wand
oh so we don't we don't get the shot of
the niffler there but I don't think you
go to all this trouble if you're not
going to allow us to have pets in there
or a pet
at least a pet
and then we also had that bit in the
the most recent bit of news right here
about the moon calves about caring for
Moon calves
which is this one right here
mooncalf instructions brush once a day
feed Moon calf
pelts or pellets
foreign
once a day with fresh
can't see the rest of it right here
hey welcome to the new subscribers thank
you guys so much
[Music]
Ravenclaw companion as Sebastian's twin
oh now that would be a twist
that would be a twist
[Music]
well we don't know about we don't know
1873 Leo for sure that's why that's why
I was just showing that
so see here it says pre-1873 even that
like they don't know exactly and this is
based on
so right here when the Dumbledore family
moved to godrex Hollow in 1890 after
percival's arrest Matilda was already
into see this already an adult part
though
they're they're just gleaning that now
it's it's a guess based on
I I can't find why they're saying she
was already an adult I really can't I
went back and read this chapter
I think it's a little bit of a stretch
to say already an adult most likely yes
but it's not it's not confirmed by this
chapter here but anyway Matilda was
already an adult and came by to welcome
them meaning she was at least 17 years
of age so see it's like then they
this makes 1873 bathilda's latest date
of birth
but it could have been earlier could
have been earlier as well
Brandon what is up dude retro man look
at you with so many views I remember
hanging out in Smash lobbies a few years
ago throwing grenades no way what was
your uh what was your name over on
Twitch was it Brandon over there too
oh my gosh Noob 3 13 in the morning wow
yeah exactly if it was any time before
that then the theory goes out the window
but it like I said it was honestly more
just a fanfic type
crackpot Theory than having any hard
evidence behind it
so I'm not I'm not like too uh I'm not
going too all in on it just more of a
fun one than anything
but yeah we do see a Rossi was asking
about grab horn we see a grab horn too
where we're like
petting the graph horn but it's not in
that spot right there here's the one
with the uh oh that definitely looks
like that is in the same spot though
inside the Menagerie
looks like it's exactly the same spot
[Music]
I want to get the grab horn scene too I
think the grab porn scenes right around
this
[Music]
there's the little niffler
there it is yeah there's the grab okay
so the grappling scene
that one definitely looks like that's in
the menageries
but that one could also be just out on
the grounds too
definitely be out on the grounds
oh dude yes I remember you Brandon I
remember that name can Kendrick and
playing uh playing smash for sure
yeah dude we've we've built quite a
solid awesome amazing audience here on
YouTube so right now we're just doing
these like kind of once a week streams
but uh I'm I'm wanting to get back into
game streaming too it's just a matter of
of time right now oh dude we actually
played through all the music let's jump
back to the beginning if you guys are
wondering where this music comes from
it's a Celtic medieval Tavern Music
non-copyright volume three I keep saying
every week I need to find a new one to
share with everybody but I just
this is just a good one to go to you
know and I know like it hasn't gotten me
copyright
claim yet which is the always a big
worry when you do YouTube live you don't
want to get hit with any copyright
strikes or uh copyright claims
[Music]
stay hydrated I'm almost done with my
Coke Zero here
yeah Brianna Nico Nico's an OG fan as
well of the when we were streaming on
Twitch Nico pulled out
how I knew Nico was a long time fan is
when Nico was talking about the
oh my gosh when did we do this
I pulled out a Guitar Hero guitar for I
think it was like our smash party night
or something I called it
or maybe it was Mario Kart
Logan with another Super Chat the two
dollar Super Chat would you ever create
a Discord Logan
my friend
we have a Discord which we are I'm
actually working with I owe Nico uh
direct message on this right now
but we are actively working on improving
the Discord so definitely go ahead and
join let me get you a link here
but there's a little bit of conversation
that goes on there but we're definitely
wanting to build it up and make it even
better so
actually let me see if I get a command
for it
fingers crossed do I do I I don't think
I do
I don't think I do
that's fine though that's fine
all right
I was gonna say Nico will beat me to it
probably thank you Nico thank you yeah
there's a link to the Discord anybody uh
go ahead and join if you want
go ahead and join
bro I miss running this lobby with snake
actually quit going to locals like oh
really
dude my son was playing Smash Brothers
tonight just ran I mean totally randomly
he hardly ever plays that game and I
haven't played in ages
but I had a little moment a little
moment thinking about some of the
memories there when he was playing
tonight
grab porns are Dragon dogs changed my
mind Steve says this game gives me Fable
Vibes I don't know why they're
completely different games
well I mean there's you know there's
that fantasy setting I at least got that
going
fantasy setting open world action RPG
but thank you so much Logan for the
Super Chat very much appreciate your
support
uh Josh what's up retro glad you're
still alive much love as a Harry Potter
fan hey Josh thank you for stopping by
and hanging out
yeah discord's totally totally uh
there's no paywall or anything everybody
can join has access to everything
Mary yep so feel free to join
wish I could do magic
teleport or evaporate everywhere don't
care for the other stuff much oh like if
I could choose one magic power yeah I
always say flight like it would be it'd
be useful
but there are definitely other magical
abilities that would be more useful I
just think free flight on your own will
be so amazing
in some way I mean teleportation would
be a lot more powerful but flight would
be more fun
flight would be so much more fun
Arian uh seems like my guess in podcast
nouns guess about a daily companion
tidbit well I think a lot of people were
hoping that I certainly was too yeah
when they dropped dropped the one on
Monday
it just clearly seemed like they were
setting up for one a day
now I will say though
they're five days in a week
and we only know about three companions
so even if they wanted to reveal the
fourth
they could skip a day
they could skip a day
so we could still get it we'll see
tomorrow
[Music]
Nathan been a fan since the exact day of
the first trailer for Hogwarts Legacy
nice
yeah that first trailer is when I
decided to start making making Hogwarts
Legacy videos yep
that was when it all started oh and that
ties into Brandon's question too so
Brandon to make a long story very short
when the pandemic happened I had a lot
of extra time on my hands because I was
off work
and
I was able to really go all in and like
learn YouTube so I kept up the streaming
too
for a while I was still streaming on
Twitch yo Steve with the two dollar
Super Chat Steve thank you so much for
the support of the stream with that
Super Chat no pets you talking uh for
the game or for me personally I I do
have a pet I have a dog her name is Luna
she has made appearances on stream
before she is a West Highland Terrier
and she is
she is passed out in her bed right now
her bed is like in the corner of the
room over there I do have a second oh my
gosh I still have my Logitech C920 I
should set that up as like a second cam
a doggy cam have it where it's just
facing her over there
I already have enough wires as is though
so
I don't want any more clutter on my desk
but yeah she makes an appearance
occasionally if you're talking about
pets in game though somebody actually
just asked that I do think I do think
we'll have pets in games in the game
yeah
with the whole Menagerie thing for sure
for sure
but uh let's see we were at answering
dude oh my gosh now Dylan
Dylan dropping a 20 Super Chat hope
everyone is enjoying the stream show
retro some love and hit that like button
#replay Squad hey you heard the man I
didn't I didn't say it guys I had to I
had to
I got a shout out the Super Chat it's
Dylan moderator here Channel member here
sporting the purple retro badge dude I
don't think I've you might be one of the
only ones I've seen with the purple one
I think that's for the
I can't remember how I have it set up
like I think I have one for one month
for two months for three months six
months and then maybe nine and a year I
think
the year the year one will go back to
the blue but it's like uh it's like the
full logo like the circle with a blue
outline
the first one is a badge that's like
just the logo in the square in blue
but yeah then we work up to the one
that's like uh I should I should have
somebody make that as like gold oh
Nico's got that's right Nico's got the
purple too
Nico's got the purple too
but Dylan dude thank you so much for
showing showing the love to the Stream
with the Super Chat
but uh I was answering that question
from uh
which question was I answering from
Brandon from Brandon about the the
transition but yeah I had all this extra
time on my hands and learned really just
went all in learning YouTube so I
started doing YouTube and the streams
well then as we started reopening things
I went back to work and so I had to
choose right I had to decide do I keep
going all in on YouTube or did I just
keep going with twitch because it just
got too much doing both and so I I chose
YouTube and haven't really looked back
haven't looked back and then I've only
recently within like the past I guess
this is probably our I don't know we've
been doing the live streams for a couple
months now so that's something I've
added more recently on top of all the
videos but right now we're just doing
the once a week Tuesday nights is kind
of our go-to night
but eventually I'd love to work up to
where we're doing more streams and uh
like gameplay streams too
only save you're heading out hey Oni
thanks for stopping by have a good one
have a good one magical class subject
looking forward to the most herbology
Transfiguration charms
oh
I mean defense against the dark arts for
sure but I'm gonna say Transfiguration
I feel like that one just there's so
many unique gameplay elements that you
can pull from with Transfiguration it'll
be really interested to see how they
handle that one
bring on the doggo cam I know dude it
would be fun I used to have her bed kind
of moves around too based on where my
desk is at the time I think I'm pretty
satisfied with this spot though I don't
I don't foresee myself moving any
rearranging the room anytime soon and so
you guys can tell like I'm pretty close
to the wall back here so there's really
not a lot of room for her bed here if we
had her bed back here though I could the
webcam I have you can like change around
the position of it very easily
foreign
think purple is two months but that
means three essentially ah okay
I know I have a purple I know I have a
green I know we have the blue I think
there might be a red one too
[Music]
oh yeah Brandon smash Mario Kart that's
right dude
[Music]
for you wanting teleportation the 3DS
destination determination deliberation
exactly
[Music]
so taken aback being in your chat again
moved moved met your wife among other
things oh my gosh well congratulations
dude yeah you'll know a lot of uh it's
funny man like how
for a bit every now and then some people
from the from the old twitch will pop in
like Chris stallion he and I still talk
every now and then but he he's in a
different time zone now than he
previously was so he's hardly ever able
to be around
for the live streams and stuff anymore
but I still check in with him every now
and then and uh
what was his name on Twitch I think it
was Master Vader what's his name on
Twitch
he still pops up every now and then and
I've I've thought about doing some
streams on Twitch too but honestly like
just let everybody shows so much support
of the YouTube streams I'm like why
would I I don't know
I'm struggling to rationalize why would
I why would I try twitch again when
when people show up so well to the
YouTubes I do feel like
if I did more dedicated gaming streams
then it might be interesting this one's
more talk show Vibes so it makes sense
to go on YouTube with all my other stuff
four months that's kind of that's kind
of wild isn't it
wait four months till Hogwarts no it's
not four months to Hogwarts because
we're just in October
it's February
hot dog dog in the house as well I'm
back finally could pass by the live
you're not dead hey
glad to hear it hot dog thanks for
stopping by dude good to hear from you
yeah I was like no it's not four months
it's February man
you're you're skipping a month or two
month and a half or so in there
because let's see today is October 4th
so
November December January February so
four months yeah
wait four months hold on it what
no way a little bit more than four
months
dude
that is crazy
for a second I was like wait no there's
no way it's four months there's no way
it's four months
I always do that thing where I think a
lot of us do this we're in in our minds
there's sort of that mental block where
January always feels like so far away
so like even when December rolls around
January's just one month away but it's
always like oh that's next you know
that's the next year that's the new year
oh my goodness
Marvin that's that's masturbator from
twitch
you lost your six month sub status no
I mean I hope honestly I hope you didn't
stay sub dude since I stopped streaming
I hope you didn't stay subbed over there
because I think it'll give you the
option like I mean there you set it up
to where it just automatically Marvin
good to hear from you dude yeah I'm
still I'm still on Eastern time yeah
[Music]
four months and five days Noob says Levi
heading out very soon Levi thank you so
much for being here dude nice chatting
with you have a good night and a good
rest of your week
dude it is wild Neil it is wild
I still like just saying four months
I got I gotta get ready man I gotta
request time off work I gotta start
planning out videos
I've gotta I've gotta do a lot of
preparation
because once that game hits
it's just gonna be a a marathon
an absolute Marathon
stay to play was six months ago
[Music]
I knew wait if February is four months
away it's only two months of the year
what the
nah it's just how math that weird
sometimes maths weird like that
stop subbing after two months after my a
yeah I don't blame you dude I don't
blame you
do not blame you
oh the trailer let's find uh
wait it's just replaying the trailer
again nah don't replay the same one
again
oh dude that's cool like when you click
on Hogwarts Legacy
oh my gosh somebody has a Hogwart so I
can see countdown stream what the
foreign
why is this video getting served that's
a six month old video
I'll take it though I'll take it
yeah you can see all the recent uh
recent Hogwarts videos I've been
watching if everybody expect to go
podcast now with your PhD
let's throw on the ASMR
actually Let's do let's do the summer
ASMR
foreign
goes by flying yes it does yes it does
it's Mr Moe what's up Mr Moe
excited for this game just told by my
local GameStop they could have a couple
Collector's Editions at launch
dude the collection Edition thing is
still so weird to me and the fact that
it's only
it was just available for such a short
span of time on only GameStop
have they ever had any on Amazon at all
have they ever had any on Amazon
I know Best Buy had like a few but I
don't think I ever heard anything about
Target anything about Walmart I just
stopped looking I was trying to keep
people updated but everything was just
so sporadic you I mean we still you just
never know when they're gonna pop up I
did tweet out a few days ago they had
some
um GameStop had the collector's edition
PC available
for a actually for like a full 24 hours
it was open
Nico don't like twitch's 70 30 Revenue
split stream on YouTube and just have a
second channel for it
you think you think a second channel for
like gameplay streams because I have the
second let's play Channel but I still
only have a few videos on there and I
can't decide what I'm gonna do with it
like if I'm gonna
full commit to it or not
because honestly it's a lot more work
than people think even though it's like
just
unedited Let's Plays there's still
just like the act of like having to set
up the recording and then all that
footage man because they're so long like
that takes a while to export you still
have to you know I try and if there's
load screens in games you gotta cut out
all so you do have to do a little bit of
editing then you still have to do
thumbnails and all that but yeah the uh
the revenue split on Twitch is a little
Annoying and the ads is definitely uh an
issue too just how they it's like every
30 minutes it's like you're getting hit
with ads whereas at least right now
on YouTube that's not how it is
that is not how it is
but yet so twitch the revenue split is I
think it's 50 50. on YouTube it's 70 30.
you get a better split on
no I'm pretty sure hold on Nico I think
you might have it
or maybe I've got the it's better on
YouTube for sure
I retweeted this because there was I
might have to scroll back a bit to find
it because it was
but there's a guy who works at YouTube
on the day all of that news broke about
uh twitch changing their
[Music]
because they just changed their right
here yeah
friendly reminder on YouTube gaming all
creators receive 70 of all fan funding
membership super chats Revenue
Etc
so on Twitch I think it's 50 50 now for
everybody
oh wait so you're saying twitch is
no twitch is not 70 30. the other way
dude there's no do they take 70 percent
surely not
yeah it's a lot of ads too
foreign
[Music]
twitch was 50 50 yeah that's what I was
thinking but
what's a racking tour
I have no clue what a raconteur is
says uh Timothy Ninja
I'm surprised you never asked Timothy
you've been in here for a while I'm
surprised you never asked that yeah
Brandon got it Brandon one of the OG's
got it yeah it's Storyteller basically
yep
[Music]
yep I'll show you
raccoons
a person who is skilled in relating
stories and anecdotes interestingly
I mean at the end of the day that's what
I always try to do right
try to tell a story with you guys you
know
stories of video games stories of gaming
news things that are going on
it took me a long time to land on that
name though it took me a long time to
finally uh
find a name that was like unique
there you go careless dreamer got it too
means retro is full of it oh that's
funny
oh yeah yeah you can there was one day
where ps5s were available on uh
the PSN Sony direct for like a full day
a full day
yeah Timothy that that was my that's how
I understood it as well for a while that
was how it was everybody got 50 50 and
some of the bigger creators got better
splits then they changed that though
recently and now now I think it's to
where nobody on Twitch gets 70 30.
YouTube it's all 70 30 which in on the
side of the Creator yeah somebody was
asking is this shirt
I saw this comment fly by I apologize I
missed it it was djane as this one of my
no this is not one of my shirts this was
a I'm pretty sure this was a t Fury
shirt years ago
yes it is it was a tea Fury shirt but we
did add since you asked djane
we did add some new merch
to our store as well
so the easiest way to get there honestly
is go retroarackintour.com and then just
hit this merch button right here
[Music]
and we just added one for the
unforgivable curses
this is not a shirt that I will ever
wear
but we did a poll
and I asked people what kind of shirts
do you guys want to see this one was one
of the biggest ones so I'm like okay you
guys want it we'll deliver of course uh
order of Merlin still available as well
these aren't gonna go away but with uh
it being October now Halloween I thought
you know what it's time we bring out
it's time we bring out the unforgivable
curses and where we are getting into the
more colder months now also doing this
one in the the hoodie as well if you're
interested if you're a channel member
any of you who just got one of those
gifted memberships
then you can get a discount
just go to the YouTube my YouTube
channel go to the Community page and
you'll see all your benefits and there's
a code for uh members so if you want
anything on here I think it's for 15 off
oh yeah we got Merlin on the uh
phone cases for Merlin mugs stickers all
that stuff from Merlin too
no Nico I I just showed you
this guy works for YouTube right here
YouTube it's 70 all creators get 70.
oh wait I'm scrolling back too far sorry
you we already talked about this I
thought that was a new comment my bad my
bad
my bad
yeah yeah Mary if you remember it's got
a uh
a little code that you can get to Trevor
heading out hey Trevor thanks so much
for stopping by
have a good one
oh Nico's got the break down here now
current twitch model for Revenue works
on a 50 50 split
while bigger streamers get more generous
70 30. yeah this will change June 2023
if streamers will get to keep 70 of the
scription revenue on the first 100K
earned
and the share will then revert to a 50
50 split gotcha okay
first hundred thousand
oh my gosh
ah wouldn't we all like to imagine that
OverWatch struggling to get onto
OverWatch oh I'm not surprised I'm not
surprised
flamed me live
sorry it's because I went back I went
back and I thought it was a new comment
I'm like dude I literally just showed
you I showed you the tweet from the man
working at YouTube come on now
no that's my fault I was scrolling back
in the comments there
[Music]
oh where did our oh I think no there it
is so it's like I think I cut away from
the ASMR
crazy to think what a community this
game is built even before the game comes
out right
uh it's supposed to be candle frog it is
supposed to be on the switch
but they have said very very little
very little about it
very little
including no release date so
honestly like I've told people I know
you know money's tight for everybody
right now if you have any other option
like if you could save up and even get
an old uh like get an old
Xbox One or a PS4
I think those are even gonna run this
better than the switch I really do
I really do but I I have nothing to base
that off of other than I mean I
shouldn't say I have nothing to base
that off of we haven't seen it so we
can't say for sure but who knows when
it's even gonna release
who knows
[Music]
Mary things like this make me torn
between whether I should keep streaming
on Twitch have more followers then
subscribers on YouTube or if I should
just make everything on YouTube
oh that's a tough it's a big question
Mary it is
like it depends on what your goal is
first of all
if your goal Mary is to
just do it as a side thing and just like
have fun and and see where it goes I
would stay where you're at if you really
want to start trying to build an
audience though
I would I would transition away from
live streams
this is just my what worked for me I
would transition away from live streams
and I would make content
that's what I would do
I would make content for either Tick
Tock or YouTube or both
and you know it could be Hogwarts Legacy
Harry Potter could be whatever else
you're into you know
go that way
and just build good content and just
stick to it for like you don't have to
bite off too much you know like try a
video a week
I was pandemic and off work so I
committed to two videos a week and I was
able to stick to that just you know
start small stick to it
do a video a week two videos a week if
you can
stick with it for like three four months
six months see what happens
see what happens and then so my like my
plan is to slowly
like this was a test run like doing
these live streams was kind of a test
to see how they would go
I'm slowly gonna start to add more
streams back
maybe go to two nights a week maybe
eventually get to three nights a week I
don't know three nights a week would be
tough three three nights a week would be
really tough with everything else I have
unless I was doing this like full time
you know
if I stream I need to play Harry Potter
connect oh my gosh I don't even have a
uh I never had a Connect
I've never been an Xbox guy
we might have to like that would be a
fun video like hunting down Harry Potter
connect
hopefully it's super cheap and not super
expensive on eBay or something
doesn't the steam deck have better
Hardware yeah yeah
it does indeed
but I mean it keeps getting rumored it's
like is the room we're ever gonna die
that they're coming out with a new Pro
switch or whatever I mean switch to it's
the rumor that will not die
they definitely need to it's definitely
time
[Music]
they get long-term confident retro and
you marry can make 100K on Twitch
a long-term YouTube is better
you mean 100K Oh you mean 100K oh my
gosh dude if I was making 100K whoa
I definitely would not be
having a
my full-time job this would be my
full-time job that's for sure
that's for show first I thought you
meant 100K Subs I'm like oh yeah I can
I'm like saving the spot on the wall
dude the spot on the wall for the uh the
Youtube plaque
I know it sounds crazy man but I think
we can do it I think we can hit it
before Hogwarts Legacy
definitely in the month or so after the
game launches who knows I may eat my
words we may come back to this month's
later and say oh the game was a flop and
my channel dies and everybody unsubs
it's it's possible
but
I think in the months after the game if
I if I really get a lot of good content
out there we'll have a huge influx of
new people discovering the channel
discovering the game
[Music]
I have a PC I use for work but I want to
play it on PS5
uh what do you I'm not sure what you
mean depends I mean it depends on the PC
that you have for work really
and if you already have a PS5 I'm
unclear if you're if you already have a
PS5 I mean
I would honestly get it just for the
extra the free extra mission
if you already have it now if you
already have the PC and it's a pretty
decent PC then I would just stick with
the PC probably
two videos a week Vaude for the twitch
stream going up on YouTube currently
streaming once a week ah gosh used to be
two streamschools. yeah that's like
it was really hard to keep up the
streams and the videos yeah
I can see that
steam deck is on the way Noob oh dude
Noob I'm
I have hovered on the pre-order or not
pre-order I have hovered on the buy
button a couple times
and I haven't went through I haven't
went through
but I have I've been very close a couple
times
I mean it's kind of like I feel like it
would be you know business expense it's
content I could make content on it
I mean especially when Hogwarts I guess
it comes out will does Hogwarts I guess
he run on the steam deck do some videos
on that
I keep going back and forth between like
wanting to commit to being a primary PC
Gamer somebody who's asking which am I
going to play on I'm gonna play on PS5
I'm gonna play on PS5 I mean really for
I probably would anyway PlayStations
just it's been my home for a while now
since the PS3 era
but then when they announced the extra
mission and stuff I know it's a annoying
practice and a lot of people don't like
it but like since I have a PC and I have
a PS5 so it makes the decision easy for
me I might as well go PS5
might as well
let me know it's any good yeah I've been
watching so many videos on it I mean I
feel like it's
I feel like it's pretty clear what it
can do I just I don't know if I would
use it that much because I'm already
I've read a lot of comments though and
seen some videos of people who say it
actually they're gaming even more now
because
the freedom that it offers you so like I
could you know there are some nights
when I could be playing a game but I
wanna you know I'm hanging out with the
kids or hanging out with the wife you
know we're watching something and we're
just watching uh TV you know and so it's
like I do have the switch but man just
the idea of being able to play something
on my PC
then through like the steam Cloud the
save then pick it up on the go oh that's
the dream dude that's so awesome and I I
wish Sony would make another Vita oh I
love the PS Vita loved it
I mean because pretty soon if the steam
deck has shown us anything it's showing
us that we're we're close man we're
close to being able to have that sort of
dream scenario where everything runs
on everything just like scaled down
which I know steam deck's not like 100
compatible with everything not even
close to 100 but
seeing some of the the incredibly
demanding games that it can run but you
know scaling down the graphics running
at a lower FPS that kind of thing
it's real exciting for the future
of of gaming I think
you would delete your whole Library
yeah steam deck is it's definitely more
powerful than the switch
and we're Sony is even getting closer
man they're they're slowly dipping their
toe in it I just saw a thing from Herman
Holst today talking about how they're so
everybody knows they're bringing more of
their stuff to PC
but he said that he doesn't he thinks
they'll
PC games will be like a year away so
like
I don't know if he means like new games
or what so like God of War is getting
ready to hit on PS4 PS5 does that mean
this time next year ragnarok's gonna be
on PC
because I can't wait and I know a lot of
Sony fans get upset by this I can't wait
till it's just day and date like just
day and date PS5 and PC why not why not
just just do it just just go ahead and
make the jump man that's the future I
feel like you could still keep making
your consoles you would still I think
they would still sell a lot of consoles
because there are some people who just
don't want to go through
I mean PC does require a bit more
maintenance there's more tinkering that
goes on sometimes there are some things
that don't always work 100 you've got to
tweak with if you just want that simple
experience you go with a console I still
think they'd sell plenty of consoles but
I don't want to get too far on that
soapbox because console Wars I know
right
uh these clips right here this is the
ASMR video this one is the summer ASMR
in in glorious 4K resolution a hot
summer day these are all available on
the official Hogwarts Legacy account
Ventress that's
my struggle
that's my struggle
I wrote about this in my most recent
newsletter Nico's big PC Gamer so we
were we were chatting about this but
I feel like I have too many little
nagging issues with PC for me to for me
to go all in on PC
that aren't even the fault
of the PC necessarily
but doing what you do when you have a PC
you try to tweak everything am I
overclocking do I do I need oh I need to
turn off my overclock for this oh well
this game oh man the graphics card is is
it it's running really hot in this game
what do I need to do to fix that gosh
the fan the fans sound really loud oh my
Game just crashed why is my game
crashing
there's this problem that persisted for
I play a ton of Apex Legends or I used
to play a ton of it don't play as much
anymore but I was playing at least three
four times a week and I would get
crashes I mean just hard reset right in
the middle of the game there was this
whole thread on the EA forums about it
it went on for months and months and
months I tried everything I even
upgraded my Ram upgraded my Ram
tried so many things and then just a few
weeks ago they random they finally
figured it out they finally figured it
out and they put out an update and now
it's fixed
but it's just like oh all that time and
then my son and I recently he's starting
to get into fortnite so you guys can't
see this but behind my computer monitor
like that way I have a little couch
there and then a TV so he sets up there
on the TV playing on the PS5 and I sit
back here at the PC and we can play
fortnite in the same game together but
my game is running terribly it'll go
from like a hundred and
70 plus frames just these random frame
drops just these and I've I've even
turned down settings
again it's a huge so it's like I just
want to be able to there are days it's
like I have so little time to game I
just want to turn it on and know that
it's gonna work
Eagle I I can confirm anything right
dude oh my gosh it still has crashes
yeah
and then there's there's like little
things too like when sekiro first came
out I play with a dual shock a dual
sense controller it didn't have
PlayStation button prompts and you had
to like put in a mod for it
was it easy to do yes did it take an
extra 15-20 minutes though before I
could get into the game yes
so one day I would love if everything
was just like seamless
on the PC
with PlayStation and everybody but even
then I might still opt for console I
don't know
I don't know
[Music]
gotta be careful with fortnite spent way
too much time I played a ton of fortnite
back in the day a ton of fortnight when
it first for the first like I don't know
six seven seasons I played so much of
that game I mean I was like one of the
OG players of fortnite I a couple of my
buddies they were even before me they
played a ton of it and finally got me
into it I mean even before I'll tell you
how long ago it was that I played
fortnite it was before the game ran at
60 FPS on console
that's how long ago it was the game used
to be 30 on console and when they
updated that and it was 60 FPS oh my
gosh our minds were blown
our minds were blown
just not computer savvy enough to get
all that have my good old PS4 works for
me
[Music]
shrewd monkey gonna make Voldemort look
like a child oh my goodness
yeah dude God of War right around the
corner right around the corner
what are my PC specs uh 2060 super is
the graphics card
and then I got a ryzen 5.
what is my
hold on
hold on let me pull it up here
let's see
The Horizon 5 5600 x 32 gigs of RAM
Windows 10
and uh the 2060 super
which
has always has runs anything I throw it
I I mostly play uh at 1080. and then I
just recently got a 1440 monitor so
that's a little more demanding but
nothing like 4K
tomato town oh my gosh tomato town
all right well you guys you know what it
is about that time it is almost 11 p.m
my time
it has been an absolute blast it's been
an absolute blast hanging out with you
guys uh we got a new video hitting
that's why I'm hopping off uh well it's
not real early I was gonna say it's a
little bit early but I gotta finish up
that video get ready to go up at 10 A.M
eastern time in the morning it's gonna
be all about the latest Hogwarts Legacy
news if you were here for the stream
then you got the full breakdown but if
you just want the quick little the quick
bits of information covering all the
news that's going to be going live at
10. so you guys can look forward to that
and I plan on being back next week we
will see if we get around to any other
Hogwarts Legacy news this week is that
gonna just be the one little character
card they release is that gonna be it
we'll find out
but thank you guys so much for the new
members all the new Subs the gifted
memberships the super chats just crazy
amount of support
crazy amount of support tonight
[Music]
only rookie hours I'll be up a lot later
new but I'll be up a lot later
gotta get that video ready gotta get it
ready
but thank you guys so much for hanging
out I hope you all have a wonderful rest
of your week a wonderful rest of your
evening
and I will talk to you all again very
soon so as we usually do on our way out
you might see an ad I'm gonna hit the
hit the ads they will roll on the way
out but uh feel free to head on out if
you want to stick around and support the
stream you can watch the ad for a bit
but thank you all so much for watching
and I will talk to you again soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]